do you
love jupiter do you love it so much you
could
look at it every day i hope so
because it just took the moon's place
and earth will never be the same again
why would earth no longer be a planet
why would only half of our world get
this spectacular view
and could you survive on this new earth
this is what if and here's what would
happen
if we replaced the moon with jupiter
overnight
no one is quite sure how jupiter
replaced the moon overnight
all anyone knows is that it's a
beautiful
and terrifying sight this
gas giant is 11 times larger than earth
so depending on where you were it could
take up a huge portion of the sky
but it's not just our sky that would
change
jupiter would transform the earth in
several ways the moon doesn't orbit the
exact
center of the earth instead it orbits a
point
4 671 kilometers off center
inside the earth it's called the berry
center
if you were able to combine the earth's
mass
with the moons the berry center would be
the center point
with jupiter in our skies the berry
center would shift and
i mean it would really shift
jupiter is 317 times
heavier than earth so the berry center
would move from
inside the earth to inside jupiter
drastically changing earth's orbit earth
wouldn't be a planet anymore instead
we would be jupiter's moon
okay so we would live on a moon
no big deal right well no it would be
a huge deal now that the earth orbits
jupiter
it would be tidally locked jupiter's
strong gravitational pull would cause
one side of the earth to always face
jupiter
and earth's other side would always face
towards
space the earth would still complete
one full rotation on its axis in one day
it would also take the same time to
complete one orbit
around jupiter you'd still have 24-hour
days but
a year would be twice as long
in its usual orbit jupiter takes
142 earth months to travel around the
sun
in its new position jupiter would take
27 months
if you were to live on the side of earth
that didn't face jupiter
your days would seem normal as the earth
passes
in between jupiter and the sun but your
nights would be dark
and moonless but at least you'd have the
stars to enjoy
if you were to live on the side of earth
facing jupiter
your days would have less sunlight
depending on jupiter's position in the
sky
it could partially or fully block out
the sun
and every day you'd get to feast your
eyes on a solar eclipse
and jupiter would bathe your nights in
yellow light
since it would reflect 50 percent of the
sunlight that hits it
and that's really bright when you
compare it to the moon
the moon only reflects 12 percent of the
sunlight hitting it and
it's a lot smaller than jupiter so
if you turn up the brightness and make
it larger
that's one giant night light it doesn't
sound
too bad yet but that's because i've
saved the nastiest consequences for last
remember i said that earth would be
tidally locked
well because of that earth could
experience
tidal heating too there would be a much
stronger gravitational force
on the part of earth facing jupiter than
on the side facing space
and that would start distorting the
earth's shape
deadly earthquakes would become common
as
parts of earth were ripped apart and
violent volcanic eruptions
would destroy cities and pollute our air
we're just lucky that jupiter didn't
bring its other moons into our
neighborhood
one of jupiter's moons io is undergoing
the same
type of deformation making it the most
volcanically active world
in the solar system and it's not
just jupiter's fault the other moons
orbiting jupiter
force io into an elliptical orbit
making the disastrous effects of tidal
heating
even more catastrophic unfortunately for
us the earth's orbit would continue to
be more like a circle
but earth's geographical transformations
would
still be enormous and you'd see
massive migrations as people moved to
safer places
and it's not just the volcanoes and
earthquakes that could kill you
radiation from jupiter would blast our
planet
killing or mutating all life forms
oh and one more thing jupiter's
gravitational force
attracts asteroids and we
would be right in their way it's
looking like you'd have to move
underground
to survive so as pretty as jupiter is
i'd rather it stay where it is
628 million kilometers away from earth
and
if jupiter were to replace the moon is
it
possible that jupiter would eventually
swallow the earth
would we pass right through its gassy
mass
well that's a story for another
what if